okay so in this video we're going to
discuss you know what is science what is
science and then we're going to progress
into the scientific method the steps
that are used to collect information so
let's go ahead and get started what is
science and what is the scientific
method all right so what is science well
a very vague definition of science is
that it's a process that produces
information about the natural world and
I do want to stress the phrase the
natural world because there's kind of
there's kind of a argument going on
about should we allow the supernatural
into science and and that's an argument
we're not going to pick up in this video
but currently absolutely we only look at
the natural world we don't allow the
supernatural to explain the the natural
process one thing about science is that
it's supposed to be objective and that
can be very hard for people because we
often come into an experience with a
bias we come into an experience with a
preconceived idea of what we think is
the answer and people don't usually like
to be wrong and so that's one of the
harder parts of science is to look at
something objectively to come in with a
fair and balanced expectation if you
come in with a bias well that bias might
weigh you down and kind of force you to
ignore the reality that's one of the
harder parts of science which is the
reason why in science you of course
share your results with others in case
you do have a bias hopefully your bias
will be uncovered by someone else
one thing about science is it needs to
be repeatable I just brought up that
often science experiments and in data
learned are published in journals and
shared around the world well that's so
others can repeat their experiments to
see whether or not the idea is correct
one thing about science is that there
are certain tools and skills that are
used to gather information and probably
one of the more obvious ones is the
skill of observation here we have people
doing Mike
go back observations trying to uncover
more secrets of the microscopic world
here we have just pretty much just the
opposite using a telescope to peer into
the nighttime sky and uncover secrets of
the universe in this case we have a
picture of the one of the Voyager probes
that was launched in the 1970s and these
things have been drifting around in our
solar system and now beyond since the
1970s and they've observed the solar
system and sent back to earth data
that's been collected so there's all
kinds of observations that can be done
and let's not forget one of the more
famous observations here we have a
little drawing of Isaac Newton and an
apple just bumps him on the head and
that observation of a falling Apple led
him to uncover this force in nature
called gravity well another skill
another tool that is used in science is
simply experimentation and in our
picture here we have a young lady doing
an experiment on DNA electrophoresis and
using electricity to separate small bits
of DNA that can be so that those pieces
of DNA can be analyzed in this pretty
famous experiment that took place in
1928 a gentleman by the name of
Frederick Griffith taught us that
bacteria can transfer genetic
information in the picture he injected
mice with a non deadly bacteria and no
shocker the mouse lived well he then
injected mice with a deadly bacteria and
no surprise the mice died well he then
injected the mice with the deadly
bacteria but before he injected them he
heated he heated the bacteria and
thought that that would kill the
bacteria and he was right the bacteria
was killed so the mouse lived the mouse
was not harmed and here's where it gets
interesting he then had a mixture of non
deadly bacteria mixed together with the
deadly bacteria that had been heated he
was expecting the mice to live but was
surprised to see that they died he
figured out that bacteria the
the deadly bacteria had been heated they
have DNA in them that DNA was
transferred to the non deadly bacteria
that were still alive the non deadly
bacteria became deadly and we learned
that bacteria through this experiment
that bacteria can transfer genetic
genetic information and this also taught
us that DNA DNA is the genetic material
this was at a time where we weren't
quite sure and so ultimately data is
going to be gathered by what we call the
scientific method now we're going to go
through the scientific method in more
detail so let's move on to that now
so here we have the scientific method
very general definition of the
scientific method it's a series of steps
that we use to collect information and
to solve problems and it begins with
number one asking a question or
identifying a problem or making an
observation so we're going to go through
a fictional example of this in just a
moment but once you identify it a
problem that leads to creating a
hypothesis
so constructing a hypothesis which is
just a early answer a hypothesis is what
you think the answer is to the problem
that you've just witnessed after you
have what you think is the answer that's
called the hypothesis then it's time to
actually do the experiment the
experiment is going to produce you data
that data of course has to be analyzed
and then once you've analyzed the data
you can draw a conclusion does your
conclusion support what you originally
thought does your conclusion support
your hypothesis follow the arrows there
if your conclusion does support the
hypothesis well then you still got to
repeat the experiment repeat it perform
the experiment again if if it's possible
to perform the experiment again and then
what about the other side what if your
data is not supported of your hypothesis
well then you kind of go back to the
beginning and you construct a new
hypothesis and you kind of start all
over so this right here is the
scientific method let's go through the
scientific method using a fictional
example
okay let's actually look at the first
two steps of the scientific method on
this one slide here step one is
observation or identifying a problem and
in our animation we have a young lady
laying in bed with headphones aren't
listening to music so the reason I have
this animation and this animation is
going to kind of be the basis of this
video here for the rest of the video in
our example in our in a pretend
fictional example maybe she makes an
observation
maybe she accidentally fell asleep
listening to music a few times and she
seemed to sleep better through the night
so that's her observation is you know I
seem to sleep better when I play
relaxing music throughout the night and
maybe she's sleeping better because of
the music maybe it's some other factor
but that's just something that she
noticed that's a problem that she
noticed so then step two is write a
hypothesis create a hypothesis typically
what we're going to show you is it's an
if-then statement and an example of this
might be if there's relaxing music
playing then I will sleep longer you
might often see if then because if there
is relaxing music playing then I will
sleep better because the music puts me
in a calming state where I'm able to
relax and sleep better so that's what we
mean by an if-then statement and that's
generally created step two in our
hypothesis let's move on to the next
step
okay so now we move on to the actual
foreign experimental part of the
scientific method and this is where we
actually design an experiment and when
we design an experiment what we're going
to see is that there are two parts to an
experiment two groups the first group is
what we call the control group and
what's so special about the control
group nothing literally nothing the
control group is the group of test
subjects that receives no special
treatment the purpose of the control
group is we're going to use it as a
comparison or what are we comparing it
to we're comparing it to the second part
of an experiment called the experimental
group and notice from the picture here
the picture on the Left picture on the
right they're exactly the same because
the control group the experimental group
you set them up exactly the same but
with one little difference in our
animation there she is listening to
music there's that one little difference
the one little difference between the
control group and the experimental group
is what we call the independent variable
it's the one factor that's different all
of the factors are supposed to be the
same except for what we call the
independent variable the independent
variable is the factor that we're
testing in this fictional study here
we're testing whether or not music
affects our ability to sleep well during
the course of this experiment maybe she
records herself for a month records the
amount of sleep that she gets for a
month with music and the amount of sleep
she gets for a month without music well
that's going to generate data and we
call that data the dependent variable
and I hope you see why it's called the
dependent variable because the amount of
sleep she gets which is the dependent
variable because that can be recorded
the amount of sleep that she gets
depends on whether or not she listens to
music so I hope you see why it's called
the dependent variable so anytime you're
gathering data in a science experiment
maybe you're measuring the heart rate of
people maybe you're measuring the blood
pressure of people anytime you're
measuring something numerical that's
going to be your dependent variable
let's move on to to this this situation
in a little more detail
okay so let's look at the control group
versus the experimental group in a
little more detail here here we have our
experimental group and we have the same
person may be recording the amount of
sleep that she gets over the course of
one month so she's kind of going to set
up two experiments here and during her
one month of recording her sleep she's
also exercising regularly and during the
one month where she's recording her
sleep and exercise and she's also eaten
very similar meals in the in this one
month period you know well-balanced
meals of good balance of carbohydrates
and proteins and lipids and the one
difference is if you just notice we
added earphones with music so the one
difference between the control and the
experimental group is in the fact that
she's listening to music all other
factors are the same in this case so
let's pretend that after one month of
recording her sleep she's averaging
about 6.2 hours of continuous sleep
every night and pretend that for one
month while she's recording her sleep
she averages seven and a half hours of
sleep per night when she's listening to
the music well something had to cause
that extra sleep and so by the way that
the data that we just collected is what
we call the dependent variable and I
hope you see why it's called the
dependent variable the sleep depends on
and that's why it's called the dependent
variable the sleep the amount of sleep
depended on whether or not she listened
to music and so if I were to ask you
okay examine the data does the data
support the original hypothesis that
this woman had I hope you would say yes
since all other factors are the same the
music must have caused the extra sleep
so granted this is very much a
simplified experiment here if this was
to be done for real yes there are other
factors you would have to control
besides just exercise and food I'm just
kind of using this to hopefully
illustrate a point let's move on
okay let's move on let's try this
situation again let's pretend it's kind
of the same situation let's say the
lady's going to record her hours of
sleep for a month and so in the control
group on the left no no music the
control the experimental group on the
right she's listening to music while she
sleeps
and notice how during the day for one
month however they're doing different
exercises for that one month period also
the woman's eating different meals
during that one month period where she's
recording her sleep well if I were to
show you that this data right here
pretend that the control group on the
left she slept continuously for six
hours and the experimental group on the
right continuously for eight hours I
would if I were to ask you does the data
support this original hypothesis I hope
you see something very different in this
situation in this situation we can't say
yes or no does the data support the
hypothesis we don't know the data would
be considered invalid and I hope you see
a reason why there are too many
variables in this experiment she has the
intended variable independent variable
of sleep sleeping with music and
sleeping with no music there's a second
variable with different amounts of
exercise and there's a third variable
with changing the food these are all
possible factors that could possibly
explain why the woman received an extra
two hours of continuous sleep so when
you have more than one variable you
really can't pinpoint your explanation
there's other possible explanations
that's the importance of having only one
independent variable in an experiment
okay so here's a little practice story
problem says the United States military
wants to see if soldiers with only four
hours of sleep can operate at the same
level as those who normally get seven
hours of sleep 100 soldiers are allowed
to sleep four hours a night and another
100 are allowed to sleep for seven hours
a night during the day the soldiers are
tested for their marksmanship on the
firing range well go ahead and pause the
video and try to answer these four
blanks I'm going to go over the answers
in three two one
so for name in the control group I hope
you said well that's the soldiers that
get seven hours sleep because the
control group is the group that gets the
normal and in the story it says normally
get seven hours of sleep
that means the experimental group are
the soldiers that are only getting four
hours sleep the experimental group is
the group that we alter it's the group
that we're changing and the what we're
changing is the amount of sleep and so
that actually answers my independent
variable question what's different
between the two groups of soldiers is
the amount of sleep that they're given
that's what we call the independent
variable
what's the dependent variable what's
being measured is the score on the
firing range so this little story here I
have another a few other stories so
let's practice here we go to the next
one
okay so here we have a farmer with two
bags of fertilizer and the story says
this farmer wants to test the new
fertilizer on his crops so he sections
off two large areas of his field in
section a he waters his crops as usual
and uses his normal fertilizer called
grow right in Section B he waters his
crops as usual but adds a new
experimental fertilizer called ever grow
so after one growing season he records
the growth of the crops well go ahead
and pause the video and try to answer
these four blanks go ahead and pause the
video I'm going to show the answers in
three two one
so for naming the control group I hope
you would say oh that was Section A
those are the crops that were given grow
right because the control group is the
group that receives the normal and in
this case he's always been using grow
right the experimental group would be
Section B the crops that were given this
new factor this new factor called ever
grow fertilizer so that's the
experimental group so the independent
variable if you recall it's just the
difference what's different between
section a and Section B what's the type
of fertilizer that he used and lastly
the dependent variable is the data
measured how does he know which
fertilizer worked better he has to
record and measure something and what
he's doing is recording the growth of
the crops so there's another example
let's go on to the next example
so here is another example here we have
a young student and he wants to know if
his new study method is more successful
than his traditional study method so for
one month he studies for his classes
using his traditional study method the
next month he studies for his classes
using this new maybe better study method
he's not sure if it's better yet and so
at the end of this testing period he
simply compares his grades so just like
the other examples pause the video try
to answer these four blanks I'm going to
go over the answers in three two one
so for naming the control group I hope
you said that's the one month where he
was doing traditional studying so maybe
he was making flashcards and outlined in
his textbook whatever his traditional
study method is the experimental group
that would be the one month where he was
experimenting with a new study resource
maybe he was doing online tutorials and
online simulations so I hope you see the
difference right there between the
control and the experimental group so it
says name the independent variable
what's different between those two
groups the difference is the study
method that's what we call the
independent variable it's the difference
between the control and the experimental
group and how does he know if this new
experimental method work what data is he
collecting he's comparing and collecting
his grades again granted if this was an
actual science experiment yes there
would be need to be more variables that
are controlled but I hope you see the
point that I'm trying to make
okay here's the last example pretend
that the city of Los Angeles wants to
know if there is a connection between
physical fitness and air pollution fifty
volunteers from the mayor's office agree
to be tested first they're asked to ride
a stationary bike for one hour in a
pollution free air timber a week later
the volunteers return and are again
asked to ride a stationary bike for one
hour in a chamber filled with air
pollutants common to Los Angeles their
heart rates are monitored throughout
this one-hour bike ride
pause the video and try to answer those
four blanks at the bottom I'm going to
show the answers in three two one okay
so this one might have been a little
tricky the control group are the people
who breathe the polluted air and at
first that kind of seems backwards but
then we realize well because the control
group is the group that receives the
normal and in Los Angeles its normal to
breathe fairly polluted air Los Angeles
Los Angeles is always either top three
in the nation as far as most polluted
air for the experimental group what's
different is the volunteers who breathe
clean air so that's our factor right
there because because again clean is not
the normal and so that makes that the
breathing the clean air something
different that makes it the experimental
group name the independent variable I
hope you said well the quality of the
air that is being breathed is the
independent variable that's what's
different between the control and the
experimental group and the data recorded
the dependent variable the data recorded
it's their heart rate as they pedal on
the stationary bikes so I hope these
examples helped let's move on
okay so let's get back to the steps of
the scientific method the fourth step is
what we call a data analysis and it says
data from the control group is compared
to the experimental group in the graph
you can see the data the data that we
said a few moments ago was that the
control group without music got about
six point two hours of sleep per night
and the experimental group with music
got about seven and a half hours of
sleep per night so there's the data side
by side in a nice readable graph we're
comparing the two and you can hopefully
see then we mentioned this a few moments
ago that the data seems to support the
earlier hypothesis now one thing I want
to mention is that the hypothesis will
either be supported or rejected by the
experiment it's not going to be proven
so I hope you're not going to look at
this data and say that it's proven that
it's proven that music gives extra sleep
it's not proven at this point it's
supported at this point yes but by no
means are we going to call it proven it
hasn't been repeated and retested by
others so we're not going to call it
proven yet let's move on
and then we have the fifth step the
conclusion so in this step like it says
your findings could be shared and
repeated by others a second experiment a
third experiment could be designed by
others not necessarily using the same
lady but the point is is that others
would have to repeat this or perhaps
even the person who originally designed
this experiment could repeat it
themselves but that information that
experiment would then be shared by
others so then they could be they could
also repeat it as well and over time
perhaps just perhaps and I'm not saying
this happens in a month or a year could
take decades perhaps but over time a
hypothesis could eventually become a
theory a theory develops over time you
know in the picture we have kind of a
picture just summarizing Darwin's idea
of natural selection today Darwin's idea
of natural selection is very much a
well-established accepted scientific
theory but in 1859 when he wrote the
book on the origin of species this was
really his hypothesis at the time that
organisms with advantages would survive
better and pass on those advantages to
their offspring and so hypotheses if
given the test and are able to stay on
the test of time and intense scrutiny
eventually could develop into what's
called a theory well both theories and
both hypotheses will change and can
change based on new information there
might be new information that completely
redesigns how we view natural selection
maybe not it's been 150 years of people
trying very vigorously to discredit and
disprove natural selection and they
haven't been successful so natural
selection looks like a very strong
scientific hype
and so there you go if you're in my
biology class pause the video and try to
answer these questions here I'd be happy
to check your answers before school or
after school one day go ahead and pause
the video good luck